three UNLV students are being honored
with prestigious scholarships 8 news now
reporter Brian Wills spoke to the
students about what it means to them and
how it will help them in the future
I'm still in shock I tell people like
every day like I can't believe I've won
such an amazing award Faria tavakoli a
public health major and Vesper everoe a
mechanical engineer major are two UNLV
students who were awarded the Barry
Goldwater scholarship the nation's
Premier undergraduate award in natural
science engineering and Mathematics it
ensures that I'm able to finish my
mechanical engineering degree and go
into higher education which is always a
dream that I've had the scholarships
provide up to 7 500 per year to help
fund stem education these two weren't
the only ones another UNLV Student
earned a different prestigious
scholarship Truman means a lot because
it meant that all the hard work that I
put in I mean even since high school has
really sort of resulted in this
Monumental achievement that I hope will
be able to
pushed me through my professional career
as well Zachary Billet was awarded the
Harry S Truman scholarship he is the
eighth student in unlv's history to win
the award The Truman Foundation selected
him from an impressive pool of 705
candidates from a universities across
the country he will receive 30 000 for
graduate study each of these students
plan to continue their education through
graduate school with the help from these
scholarships do what you love and that
you're passionate about because at the
end of the day all of that hard work
shows nothing is done in isolation
engineering science none of that has
done in isolation that investment of
time and resources was worth it Brian
will eight news now